From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
3 2 1 and action.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013.
My name is Dr. Hasan Kwame Jeffries at the Ohio State University and the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer Petna Dalico in Albany, Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here with Johnnie Ruth Brawner McCullar.
Thank you so much for being here with us to share your story.
I'd like to begin just by asking you where you were born.
I was born in Terrell County, in Sasser, Georgia, Georgia.
And you were born February 4, 1940.
And your parents? What were their names?
Clifford Brawner and Johnnie Lou Brawner.
And they, too, were from the area. They were from Southwest.
Yes. Georgia.
Yes. How far back did your family have roots in Sasser, Georgia?
My father's parents moved here from Worth County, which is a few miles from Terrell County. the line sort of meets.
My mother, I don't quite know. I understand from her that her family originated from some parts of Alabama when I don't know.
What was your mother like? In her youth while you were growing up?
I tried to buy it, always working.
She was always looking for something to do, canning, sewing, making quilts, always something to make sure the family had what they did.
And how about your father?
He was a hard worker. He was first, he was a farmer.
We moved off the farm in the 50s. I don't remember exactly what year.
He worked for a while at the Marine Base. And from there to the...
fertilizer plant, I can't remember the name Swift. That's the name of...
Down here.
And Albany, Georgia, yes. He retired from there after about 28 years.
Do you remember life on farm?
I didn't like it.
What was it about the life on farm that you did?
Well, I was afraid of all the animals. I didn't like the heat.
I didn't like the mosquitoes, I didn't like the gnats, all that other stuff.
And I was afraid of snakes. Very afraid of snakes.
Why not have you about that?
Now where was the farm located?
Oh goodness.
Down floor to shore, back in the area near...
It's a place called Dubgaate, back in that area.
Of Old Dawson Road.
And when your family left the farm, where did they move?
To Sassar, which is in the city of Limson, Sassar.
Now they're all home, I was asked.
You like Sassar more?
Yes.
What was it about Sassar that was more appealing to you?
Not a whole lot of snakes.
Because it wasn't the farm.
No farm.
What was life like for you?
But then you were 12, 13?
Yes.
How did life change for you when you moved to Sassar?
I can't say that it was better because we always had a good life.
We had what we needed. We was always full.
We had the clothing that we needed because my mother was a good seamstress.
So she made that clothing.
I can't say it was in a better way to move there than when we were on the farm.
It's just that I didn't have to do the farm work.
What was your responsibility while you were on that farm?
Oh, faith in chickens, milk the cow, which I was afraid of.
Sometimes I had to pick cotton.
I didn't very good at that.
So I really, I really, really, to be fair, I didn't do too much on the farm.
But what the little bit I did I wanted to have you about.
When you were working that didn't, we had talked to your brother a little earlier, Clif.
And he was saying that he didn't have to and didn't record whether or not his siblings had to.
So you were work instead of going to school.
We would work when we weren't in school.
Okay.
When it was time to go to school, we went to school.
How long was the school year?
School was always out in April.
It usually was start in October.
And so in that in between time, spring, summer, into early fall, you'll be helping out on the farm.
Yeah, what I could do, yes.
Do you remember the elementary school that you had gone to?
One room school.
The name of it was Panty Grove.
Panty Grove.
Do you remember the name of your teacher?
My first teacher's name was Vanny Wakefield, I believe.
And what was it like going to that one room school, Panty Grove?
It was fun.
Seven grades in one building, one teacher.
About how many students are we talking about?
Maybe about 40, a less.
And this is, do you stay in Panty Grove for how many years?
I think I was six grade when we left.
And then you had to wear?
To Sassar, to Dunbar.
Okay, to Dunbar.
And that's the middle school?
That was elementary school that went from first grade through ninth grade.
And was that experience different than going to Panty Grove?
Yes.
Was it all in one grade to a classroom?
And then from there you had to high school.
High school.
And what high school did you attend?
Carver High School.
And where was Carve?
In Dawson.
Yes.
What was Carve a life?
Well, it was an experience being in high school.
I met a lot of other people that I didn't know.
It was cold, both at the time, with one heater in the classroom.
You had your sitting classroom with your heavy coats on.
You know, or to stay warm.
There was no lunch room, so you had to carry your lunch.
If you had a lunch, you would take your lunch room home.
Well, it wasn't what it should have been.
We didn't have the equipment that we needed.
There were two classes, and that was a divide of between the two classrooms.
So when we had, and it was used for an auditorium,
whenever we had some type of program, they had to remove the petition
from between the two classrooms.
And you could hear what was going on in the other classroom.
So it was kind of, sometimes we kind of know as it.
And so this is the mid-1950s?
Yes.
1954 and 1950s.
End of 55, 56.
Is when you start?
When I started 10th grade.
Now, you know, the famous Brown ruling,
Stagnath's segregation and education,
as unconstitutional, had been passed two years earlier.
Was there any talk about desegregating schools at that time while you were in school?
No, because at that time, like people,
seemed to be in afraid to really discuss stuff like that.
If my member serves me right,
there was certain amount of information that you could get from government.
The black teachers, I think, were told what to teach.
So, you know, we didn't know too much about government.
How about that home?
Was it where any conversations or discussions of the sort?
My parents didn't know too much about segregation or, you know, about end of schools.
But they knew that we didn't have what we needed in order to be properly educated.
The books were pages were torn out.
We were getting them from the white schools.
They got new books.
They were passing old ones down to us.
There would be writings all over the books and pages, part of the pages, are torn out.
Sometimes, we would have one spelling book to a class.
The teacher would have to put the words on the board and you would have to write them off.
Because they didn't have enough books.
Did you ever talk to your mother or father about the way things were?
I don't recall.
How about friends?
Classmates.
We complained about having to take so many minutes out of the classroom and evening classes to clean up the buildings.
Because we had no gender or your sisters.
And so that responsibility for all of you all of us?
Yes.
And all of us.
They put down the dust compound, but it was still dusty.
So you spend your four years in high school and you graduate in 1959?
Yes.
And what do you do after graduation?
My older sister was in nursing school.
So I had to sit out of here until she graduated.
And what, do you remember the name of the school?
Do you remember where she was going?
The school was in Bibb County and Macon, Georgia, but I can't remember the name of it right now.
And so you had to stay out just because of the course?
Yes.
And so what did you do during that year?
Baby said.
In the neighborhood or for your family?
I had a customer across the street and sometimes she would break a smaller kid and I would keep them.
I basically just kept house while my mother worked.
And your mother, what did she do?
She worked, she did housekeeping works sometimes and then she worked at the high school.
She was a cook.
And this is in Sassar?
Yes.
And so then your sister finished your sister program?
So now it's your turn to go to school and you choose to go to Albany State.
Why did you choose all of these things?
I, whatever I was born of, I was kind of a sickly child.
And my parents didn't want me to get too far away from me.
So they had a little bit of a say in that as well?
Yes.
But they wanted you to go to college?
What was their thinking behind that?
Did they ever share what you wanted?
They wanted me to be a teacher.
They wanted me to go to the nursing school like my sister.
I had to do what they wanted me to do.
Was that ever a discussion or was that just known?
That was known.
This is what you will do.
No, why didn't they want you to be a teacher?
I had an instructor who was always telling me I needed what I needed today.
So she told them that so they took it from that.
So when you enroll at Albany State, 1960,
it's with the intention of becoming a teacher.
And so what do you, do you choose a major?
I, for some reason decided I wanted to do science,
but I don't know why I did that.
I wasn't that good in science.
I just really wasn't sure as I could what I was going to do.
Really.
And did you stay on campus?
Yes.
What was out like when you arrived in 1960, no longer living at home?
A lot of people.
But I enjoyed living on campus.
I did.
The only problem was the food.
Not good.
Food was no good.
I was getting hepatitis from the food.
The food was bad.
Was this something that students complained about?
Oh, yes.
Administration.
Did it choose to do anything?
No.
It didn't seem to matter.
It wasn't good.
It was prepared badly.
Well, I won't go into that.
So what was from the student perspective?
I feel that the administration was the supportive of the students.
What was your opinion about the administration?
The school as a whole?
As far as academics were concerned, yes.
But it seemed like when it came to the food, I guess they're just like the dottation took out all of that.
But food was not good.
And I would eat it.
And so I ended up becoming ill.
Did you stay here?
Did you have to go home?
I ended up having to leave because I had problems with my stuff.
So I had to leave.
Now did you, but you wanted to come back?
No, that was it.
Oh, right.
So that was 1962.
1962.
Now by then, you had, has you already become involved
with civil rights activities?
That was a march downtown.
And I don't want to get into something
I can't remember the full details.
But it had to do with a young lady named Bertha Gober.
And she's her name is the only one that
comes to mind at this point.
But we had a march downtown.
And I was involved in it.
Now, was she a home student here at Albany State?
Yeah, of an estate.
And has she been expelled?
Do you recall?
I can't remember.
Now that was a long time ago.
But you remember that that was, so the first time?
The first time, yes.
I participated in the march.
What was that experience like?
Do you remember just the experience of being on a march?
Kind of scary, because I didn't know what was going to happen
when we got downtown.
Now did you march from campus?
OK.
How'd you hear about it?
Different people talking about it.
And they were going around and recruiting people
to fly the march.
But for some reason, I got involved.
I thought, oh, wow, I just did.
And so during the march, you say you're nervous,
you're not going to show what's going to happen.
No, no, no, what's going to happen downtown?
You're fearful of the police?
And you know what?
My parents kind of say when they found out that I
had participated in the march.
So you survived that day?
Yes.
No violence, no arrest.
You get back to the dorm.
What do you think?
I got away with that.
But when my parents found out about it, they didn't get mad.
Because by then, things had started to enter accounting.
It's sort of out in the open.
People were having meetings.
And so after that, things stopped.
And things just started opening up.
And I got involved.
So after the march, you're back at the dorm.
Word reaches your parents from the parents of other students.
Do you even know?
I said, well, parents, people coming from Dawson
and sassing to school here.
And did they, was it ever even a conversation about it?
About your participation at that time?
The head cook at the school where my mother
wrote, mentioning it to her.
I know your daughter has better sense than to get involved
in something like that.
And she's also where she did it.
And this is a white woman.
She's here.
And she did it.
So that was the end of that.
And did that head cook ever say anything else to her
at that time?
I don't know.
If she mentioned it again.
And so after that march, you participate.
Your parents, hey, that's OK.
That's OK.
Do you still at Albany State?
Did you haven't gotten sick yet?
Do you get involved in other activities?
Other marches and demonstrations?
No, that was him.
Why was that?
I don't know.
I just never got involved again here at the school.
That was good.
So the spring of 1962, you get sick.
You head back home at that time.
And you just recuperate at the house.
Had you thought about what you're thinking that you were
going to return to school?
I thought about it.
And then I got really and truly involved in the movement.
And that doesn't work.
And to go life.
It's going to life with its own.
So your back home, you recuperating.
And things are starting to happen in terror.
Now, how do you get involved in what's happening back home?
Because when I got home, my parents were already involved.
And what were they doing?
You saying they were already involved?
Going to meetings.
They were having meetings at one of the churches in Dawson,
I believe.
It was the Zine Hill, a Sardis Baptist church.
And they moved from there to my knowledge.
OK.
the meetings have moved from there to my home.
And my knowledge was your family church.
It was a family home.
Were you starting to attend meetings as well?
And the Terrell Movement, the Terrell Movement, the organization,
when does that get started?
When I got back home in 1962, I believe they started
to get together in 1960.
OK.
They started to get, I didn't know anything about it.
But it had started in 1960.
And so how did you get involved with it?
Because at certain point, you become secretary, correct?
Out of left school, that's when I got really started getting
involved.
My parents were going to the meetings.
So I started going with them.
And the president of that movement, man's name,
his name is Lucius Holloway.
And I don't know how I got drawn into becoming the secretary,
but I did.
So there was no office to elect me.
I did somehow gotten involved.
Now, did you, you and your parents,
while you were going to those mass meetings,
were they talking to you?
Were they talking among themselves?
We talked.
We talked about it.
Whatever went on in the meetings, we discussed it.
When we got home, we talked about it.
And things that we needed to get done in the school systems
and in the community.
We wanted to become registered voters.
So we went a couple of times trying to get registered.
And the registrar would leave the office.
And where was the registrar's office at the time?
In the courthouse, in the basement of the courthouse.
The kind of courthouse.
And he was Santa Claus at the post office and washes.
When we did catch him in his office,
when we did let us become registered voters,
we had to read a scripture from the Bible
before we could fill out the form.
And when did you finally get a chance to even fill out the form?
I don't remember exactly the time and the date of that.
But we did become registered voters.
My mother lost such a job at the white school because of it.
For having registered?
Because we registered voters.
Now, five here.
Did that happen because she had actually successfully registered?
Yes.
So even before, I mean, so obviously they would keep in track.
They would keep in divs on what she was doing.
Yes.
Not happy with her attending these mass meetings
and her and her.
Was she feeling pressure at the job before she was fired?
They didn't pressure her to that point where,
she would just want to leave, but they just out,
I told her she had to go.
None you could do about that at that point.
I was telling her she had to go.
So she went to Albany and she started doing housework.
And they called her later that she was working for
and tried to get the later to fire her.
And she told, I don't have anything to do with it.
She didn't care her counting.
All I need her to do is to do what I ask her to do.
And I pay.
So she refused.
You remember who that woman was and they abandoned you?
When your mom, do you remember your mother coming home
saying that she had been fired?
From the from from from from Sassar.
Kind of, it's kind of down, but, you know,
it, we talked about it periodically.
And they should we got fired out and we didn't remember that day.
But you would talk about the fact that she had been.
Yes.
How does she feel about it?
Well, how would anybody feel on that website.
Not necessarily angry, but sort of disappointed in the way
that it was done.
You know, I have a right to become a registered voter.
This is my God giving right.
So why should you take it away from me?
Well, that's what happened.
Was there anything?
Did that change at all the way your family was involved
in the movement?
No.
Has made it even stronger?
As Secretary of the Terrible Movement,
what was some of the things that you did?
I would take notes as to what was being said.
Different people would come in and talk about the things
that they had experienced on their jobs.
The people from SNCC would come and they
would talk in like Charles Sherrod, Don Steward, Prathia Hall.
Prathia Hall Hall?
Ralph Allen.
And sometimes we would have reporters there.
So is all of the mass meetings?
Yes.
And then from time to time, the police
would press the music, Sheriff Z.T. Mathews, and his deputies
would come and they would put their feet on the seats
and just talk be ugly, really ugly.
We would sickle this mess.
They would say, I black people are doing fine.
They're happy with things the way they are.
And the outsiders are coming in and stirring up
I black people and stuff like that.
So they would physically show up at a mass meetings?
Yes.
Now when would a mass meetings tell?
At Mount Olive.
And there were Wednesdays or Sundays?
I think the meetings I believe are not
mistaken on a Wednesday night.
I believe those.
Each county saw a head there on night
that they had that meetings.
And the different counties would support each other.
Like on Wednesday night, while chair of county
was on Wednesday night, we would go to the county
if there was on Tuesday night, back in football.
About how many people would be at the mass meetings?
Maybe 30 or 40, sometimes maybe less.
It just depends.
And when Sheriff Z.T. Mathews would show up, how would that,
how would people respond?
We would keep doing whatever we were doing.
even with the singing, we would continue to sing.
If one of the SNCC workers was up talking,
speaking, they would just continue to speak.
Do you sometimes they would interrupt?
Yeah.
Do you remember meeting SNCC workers for the first time?
I'm trying to remember the first one.
I mean, I was a linguist, Charles Sherrod.
if I'm not mistaken.
What do you think of them?
Not the first time, but just as a whole?
I thought he was a very unique person.
He had a very sweet and common personality.
Never raised his voice.
Always to me, very sure of himself.
I don't think he's still the same.
How often were they in the county?
Often.
They were very visible.
They were always around.
Somebody, if it wasn't Sarrard, it was somebody
of the SNCC workers.
Somebody was always around.
Now, were there, hey, SNCC workers staying in the county?
Or were there most of them?
That was a lady.
Her name was Carolyn Daniels.
And they were staying at her house.
If I am not mistaken, Lucius Holloway
would have some boy in his house.
Nobody ever stayed with us.
But my mother would make cakes and things of that for them.
Try to get up to feed them.
You know.
Yeah.
The voter registration activity.
So yourself and your parents had gone down
to attempt to register the vote.
Did you do canvassing activities as well?
Yes.
Myself and some of the students from the high school,
Gladys Clark, who was not deceased and his sister,
Anadine Clark, we would canvas the areas in Dawson
in the evenings after school going door to door.
The people were running the house.
One day, we'll see us coming.
Here, come to Freedom Riders.
That's what they called us.
And they were going to house and clothes and do
what they were afraid to talk to us.
And those who didn't quite run or even those did,
but those who you caught up with, what would you say?
We were talking to them about becoming registered voters
and trying to encourage them to come to the meeting
so they could hear and see what was going on.
But they were afraid of losing their jobs,
of being made to move out of the home,
but they were living in because they would be ranting.
And they would just tell us, I'm afraid I get fired.
I'll have to move.
And that's the reason why they didn't want to be seen.
They didn't want to be seen talking to us.
How long would you spend out, canvassing, or an avid?
The case would get out of about 3, 3, 30.
And we would walk sometimes until we were starting to get dark.
But then we would sometimes hitchhike.
Just try to find a way home.
Were you ever worried about your safety while you were out there?
Oh, yes.
We've been crazy not to.
What were you concerned about?
The life of what not happy about what we were doing.
And that were threats.
So we had to be careful.
And being careful meant what?
You watch your back.
Any car come by, you move out of the road.
So you didn't want to get here.
And at some point, sometimes they will swing out of that.
So you had to be careful.
The cars.
The cars will swing out of that.
You would never canvas by yourself.
No.
So you would always pair up.
You always had.
That was always, but either 2 or 3 always together.
You never go out by yourself.
And the students, they were younger than you.
Yes.
So they were looking up to you.
I don't know about that.
They were always bigger than me.
I was the smallest, not many groups.
So I don't know if they were looking up to me or not.
But I was always the smallest, not many groups.
So I don't know about them looking up to me.
But we all had the same goal as to help black people get what
they were supposed to have, where they'd
been taken away from us.
That was our goal to become decent citizen, first class
citizen.
Well, some of the other activities
that the Terracan movement was doing that you were involved in.
Well, occasionally with Reverend Samuel Wells,
we would do some city and sometimes.
And who was this Reverend?
Reverend Samuel Wells.
His name was Reverend Samuel Wells.
I think he passed on.
And you would do some cities.
To some cities.
Where?
We would just go into a restaurant.
It was a restaurant in Dawson.
I can't think of the name of it.
And he would tell us what we were supposed to do before we went in.
He said, we would just go and just sit at the counter.
But just sit down.
He said if they say something, we'll just leave.
And that's what we would do.
We said, I don't want anybody to get in trouble.
And anybody to get hit in anything.
He was sort of an objector.
And you did that?
We did.
And what are we told us to do?
That's what we did.
Or else he wouldn't tell us anything that was going to get anybody hurt.
What was it like going in to some of these places?
It was scary.
Always a little scary.
But you never knew what was going to happen.
Did anything ever happen?
Well, you would get taught ugly too.
Yeah.
Called names by the patrons.
Yeah, by the owners.
By the owner, by the owners.
Well, well, well, why the person that was working there,
we don't serve you there.
You hear so.
But we just get up late.
We were not going with.
We just get up late.
Did you ever have any runs with the police?
You never ended running with police except at the church.
When they would show up?
When they would show up.
At the mass meetings.
Yes.
So we have the mass meetings.
You're doing voter registration work.
You're doing these sit-ins.
Other activities?
Were there other things that you were doing as well?
We had a after the church.
After the church was burned.
Oh, yes.
Mount Olive Baptist Church.
The series of churches.
Yes.
OK.
We had, they started a school and a dope school.
And they would teach us some of the doves
that could not read and write how to write their names there
for bands, things of that nature.
And that's what I would go there.
I wasn't a teacher, but I would attend those classes.
So like adult literacy schools?
Yes.
And who were the people who were coming in?
Some of the people's ADL sales, St. Robert,
it's Catherine Mallory.
They all now deceased.
And it would be kind of fun.
They enjoyed it.
If they were learned to say they're alphabets
and they could do them all the way through,
it would be so funny to them.
They're just rejoicing that they had learned to do this.
And all their life, they hadn't been able to do it.
Now, were they encouraged and registered a vote as well?
They'd become registered a vote.
And so that was part of it.
That was part of the organ.
We talked.
We also talked them how to vote, what to do
when they would go into the voting post.
Now, would you carry some of the people down
to the county court house?
Usually, I was one of the poll watcher.
When during the elections, I was one of the poll watcher.
And what elections were these?
What were the same?
The local elections, the national elections.
I would be a poll watcher.
And I would help people who could not read it right.
You had to sign a form to sign that you had the help.
These people had to sign the form.
Then I would help them to call the names out to them
and let them choose the one that they wanted to vote for.
So this is even 1964.
And they're done in the 60s.
So you're standing in your poll watcher meeting
that you're in a poll.
And you're watching really basically what's going on.
If anybody tried to keep people from voting basically.
Did you ever have to intervene or on behalf of somebody?
Not really.
Because the federal government was in a federal people
right here.
I want to go back to late summer 62.
You have been involved with the total movement.
And the mass meetings had been being held at Mount Olive Baptist Church
of the family church.
And then in August, the church is burned.
Yes.
Could you tell me about that?
It was like a death that someone you love had died.
I said to think that people would be so mean that they
were burned for church.
It didn't stop anything.
It's made us more determined.
How could you burn a house of God?
Because people will want to register to vote.
That's what happened.
What were some of the discussions after work?
Well, people wondering who did it, why they did it.
We're done in the middle of the night.
So nobody knew.
And I don't know if the U.S. Department of Justice
ever found out who did it.
Was there any speculation about who may have done it?
They just said the white folks did it.
So who did it?
I don't know.
Where did the mass meetings go afterward?
I'm not mistaken.
We went to the Methodist Church.
They became afraid that they were going to burn their church.
So they stopped us from doing that.
By this time, they had started the foundation
to reveal my dollar.
We would put chairs there.
And so they told us we could not do that.
So then they brought in a big tent and put it in the back.
And we held our son to services.
And our meetings in that tent.
Behind the foundation.
The foundation as that was going on.
Your brother was working with help to build that.
Do you remember how your father reacted?
To yous.
And he said some words that wasn't Christian.
Did I hold it?
How about you?
How about your mother?
Sam.
Everybody.
It was just a sad day.
As I said, it was just like a death.
Because that church had always been there.
It had always been a part of that little city in Terracan.
And you mentioned that when you were canvassing, that you had to be careful.
And now the church has been burned.
Your family, your mother loses her job.
Were you ever, was the family ever feel like they were in danger?
Yes.
Because the word was out.
That anyone who participated in the meetings and they all know how things got burned.
And they were in the homes.
So we would take turns sitting up at night and watch it.
To make sure nobody suspicious cars, were you looking for vehicles?
Anyone trying to set a fire?
Are any strange cars pulling in the yard and the, whatever?
And as you saw somebody, what was the plan?
Get everybody up out of the house.
Escape before anything could happen.
Now you have family members outside, I mean, in the community.
Relatives.
Yes.
But they also active.
And one uncle.
My father's brother, he was also active.
But some of the others weren't.
Didn't have too many family members around.
Around in the, in that area.
How about some of your friends when you have become involved?
Did they, did they also become involved when you had moved back home?
My classmate is pretty much.
Why, why, why was that?
I have no idea.
Did they treat you any differently?
No.
They just let you do your thing.
I guess so.
Most of my classmates when I came back, you know how little small towns, they have no jobs.
So you go away to school, you don't come back.
So a lot of them, they say what they were going for.
So after the tragedy at Manawa, what is the movement do then?
There were people from the U.S. Department of Justice that came down.
We had, well the Georgia Bureau of Investigation's came first.
The Georgia Bureau of Investigation.
Not, in my opinion, not to try and find out who did what.
But basically, I think just to cover them, say those.
But when the U.S. Department of Justice came down, a lot of things started happening.
They were taking statements from different people.
And they took that back to Washington, with them.
The little book that I had that I kept no sense.
They took it back.
I never got it back.
And what's this little book?
What is that?
That's a little book that I just was scribbling little notes in.
I was afraid to write down certain stuff because I didn't know who was going to get
the hands on it.
So I would just scribble certain stuff down.
Was this sort of a notebook as you would take a meeting?
Yes.
You would take a meeting as a note from the meeting.
So the U.S. Department of Justice, the investigator, the interviewer.
The interviewer.
Yes.
What was that like?
Like this one.
And you just shared.
We talked.
Yeah.
Did you think that we were going to do anything?
Yes.
What was that like?
Like this one.
And you just shared.
We talked.
Did you think that we were going to do anything?
I kind of felt like they were.
After then, people in Sasser had to go to Americus to federal court.
As part of a court case, or what would they do?
Many things that had happened in the area, the shooting at the SNCC workers, the local
police officer that we had, were shooting at the SNCC workers.
A whole lot of other stuff.
With the burning of the churches in that area, they had to go to federal court.
The shooting at the SNCC workers.
As they were canvassing, was that something that was common?
No, I don't know.
I think the local police officer let somebody put something in his head that was right.
And he believed it.
So he was taking his act.
He was doing what he thought he was supposed to do.
Tell Counties, some people called it.
Terrell County.
Terrell County, it was.
You think that was inappropriate?
Why terrible?
Because it was.
It was just.
I never run into really when I was growing up a whole lot of prejudice from the people because
my parents protected us from that.
We never worked in White folks' houses.
When?
Places of that nature.
We were always protected from that.
So some of the stuff that some people experienced, we never did.
My worst experience was when I started working with the movement.
Worst experience with White folks?
Other than that, when I was a child, I didn't know.
I knew that things they had was better than what I had with the special with the school.
We had to walk school.
They rode the school bus.
They had better books.
So that was really basically all in certain places that they could go that I couldn't go.
But then they had the places for the blocks.
So in a way, I felt like that was the way it counted, the way it was supposed to be.
I still had some places to go.
I may not have been able to go where they went, but we still have places to go.
So did when you joined it.
Back to the movement and now you're encountering and experiencing these white folks in this
sort of different way, did that change what you thought about them?
I'm seeing now what I've been missing.
You know, you couldn't go into a restaurant and sit down and eat.
If you went to get a hamburger, you had to get it through the hole in the wall because
you couldn't go inside.
So it kind of opened my eyes into what was really going on.
And how that revelation, that opening your eyes, what did you make of it all?
It made me determined to try to make things better for everybody, not just black people,
but for everybody.
Because you can't help one of this, you have the other.
That would prove why people living in that area was, I would say just as poor as I was
a poor.
So you can't help one race of people unless you have the other race.
Because the movement continued.
So into 63 and 64.
Did the kinds of things that you were doing change?
Kind of slowed down a bit.
When people became, started to become registered voters, things kind of, the canvass and kind
of slowed down a bit.
Most of it was done when people were running for elections.
And when we started camps in the area trying to support this person, to support that person,
get people out to the polls.
Make sure that nobody kept them from voting.
And they just, somewhere I in there, I stopped.
I went home to take care of my sister's baby.
She had a child and she was working.
She needed somebody to keep so my parents brought me home.
So that's what I was doing.
And then later on I got married and I moved away.
And when did you get?
1967.
And then where do you move to?
Topeka, Kansas.
I mean, so you move far.
And this is your first time really away from poll?
That far away from poll?
Was that, how was that experience for the leaving terrible behind?
Wonderful experience.
Wonderful.
And a chance to travel to see some things, you know, see other places.
It was fun.
Did you stay in Kansas for long?
Came back to Atlanta.
To Atlanta.
And I lived there for a while, but four years.
Then I came back to Albany and went to work at Phoebe Putney.
At the medical.
At the hospital?
Yes.
And what were you doing at the hospital?
Working in the CNA, Citiburn nursing system.
How had the area changed if at all when you came back?
Some places I didn't recognize.
The black and white signs were down.
You know, the black water fountain, the white water fountain.
The signs were down.
It was kind of strange, you know?
I changed a lot.
Then you could go into any restaurant you wanted to sit down.
You could go to a movie and then you
had to sit in the back and sit down on the lower level.
And now people throw things out on you.
So it was a lot different.
Were you glad to be back?
Yes.
Did you stay?
Did you live in Albany?
Or were you living in?
But my parents.
I lived back in with my parents.
And how Terrell was different.
It was different.
The schools were integrated.
It was all about it.
Everybody was riding the school bus.
It's a school.
So nobody walked into school anymore.
It was all about it.
Did you ever resume sort of movement type activities?
Yes.
I started working with NAACP.
I became a deputy registrar.
In 1979, I think I did that until 1996.
Whatever year the voting started to where you could vote,
could register to vote in any place, like whatever.
That's when I basically saw that.
I would do four hours on Saturday morning.
Registering people to vote?
Yes.
So the movement kind of stayed with you.
Why do you think that was the case?
I guess the people thought I was dependable.
So people would come out?
They always call me.
People who were in charge of what it was going on,
would always call me so.
Was the NAACP very strong?
It was.
Is it the Tereo County NAACP?
Yes.
OK.
Not as strong as it used to be.
Was that the main movement organization, if you will?
The main center sort of movement activity in the 80s, 80s, 90s?
Yeah, I believe so.
You recall what the branch president was?
JL Barnes.
JL Barnes?
He was a murder.
He was murdered?
No, I had.
1994.
Did he have anything to do with his activism?
I believe so.
So the danger for speaking out for being active didn't just
go away in the 60s?
No.
So that's one of the things that didn't change.
What do you say?
Is this idea that there were people who were opposed to change?
I don't know how to put this, but things are better.
They look good.
But there's a lot that needs to be worked on.
You know, I stuff this under the cover.
And you see the smiles and the handshakes.
And.
But everything is not coming up roses.
And I don't think it ever will be.
So what you have to do is just you do the best you can to make your life for you and
your family and other people around you as comfortable as possible.
You do what you can.
Because I don't think we as black people are going to be where God intended for us to be.
Because now people who are working every day to keep it from happening.
You got a black president.
And they're blocking him and every move he makes.
So if he can't make things better, they won't let him or what you think about me.
They're not going to listen to me either.
But I try.
We've covered we've covered a lot.
But I know there's so much more that we could possibly talk about.
Is there anything that you want to add that we pass we didn't talk about or you want to add say a little more about?
Just ask our people to become more active in voting.
Register to vote and voting after you register.
Support your elected officials and whatever they're doing because it's for your benefit.
We put them in office and then we hands off.
They need to be held accountable.
And if we don't do it, who's going to?
That's valuable advice.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.